this episode is sponsored by google play
with the help of disney princess
majestic quest
from the studio who brought you Lion
King one and a half
Mulan two and lady in the two
scamp's adventure comes a Disney
animated film that's nothing like
they're lazy direct-to-video sequels of
the past because this one came out in
theaters frozen to six years after
frozen melted your heart you grew up and
moved on to better things but when
there's money to be made some companies
just can't let it go in this scattershot
follow up wrapped around an albums worth
of b-sides that's vague and
world-building enough to set the stage
for frozen's three through seven and a
half scamp's adventure
all your favorite characters are back to
who they were at the beginning of frozen
one else's still moping on balconies
honest still caught between her sister
and a mr. Christophe has so little to do
they give him the part of a 1930s comedy
act I said you'd have to be crazy to
want to marry a man you just met wait
what crazy you didn't say I was crazy
you think I'm crazy no and Olaf is doing
his best to hold it all together until
he joins the Disney Hall of dust
but what they all lack in character
grows they make up or in costume
upgrades I already told you I want to
self-actualize Elsa with the sparkly
personal growth dress this is fearless
Queen Elsa with a cosmic dream cake
idiot and wears new permafrost Olaf are
you ready to set up on a quest to
discover the dark secret of arendelle
not so fast first listen to this bedtime
story
and then a lullaby then get a crime song
stuck in your head then everyone just
kind of meets up for a head then a song
about how every minute brings us closer
to death well we're still not often a
question okay I guess we have time for a
full game of charades then just one more
lullaby and now we'll set off on a quest
you frozen one managed to fit all the
plot and character set up into one song
with time left over to build a snowman
when our heroes finally get their ices
in gear they'll go explore the enchanted
forest known as the enchanted forest a
hidden world full of cutting-edge
particle effects and dull rejects from
Avatar The Last Airbender there they'll
learn the dark truth about arendale long
ago they betrayed the indigenous people
to the north and by long ago I mean
grandpa did it but if you think this is
setting up some hard choices or
sacrifice or even commentary on
historical injustice
it isn't everything's just fine who else
was in on the plot did the people to the
north want revenge shut up Elsa's got a
water horse now so strap in for a brand
new frozen that could get sued by thor
ragnarok if Disney didn't already own
every day we do this together okay
one Vint auto history Odin and I drowned
entire civilizations in blood and tears
but that goes against everything
arendelle stands for made of rocks as
you can see it seems to know it's less
interesting or fun than the first one so
most of the run time is spent
reminiscing about it when you pretend to
be Christ up in your life you need to go
talk these rocks but what's wrong I
climbed to the North Mountain survived a
frozen heart and saved you from my
ex-boyfriend two sisters one born with
magical powers weren't born powerless
what did happen to your parents ship
went down in the southern sea six years
ago
[Music]
do you want to build a snowman and if
you're expecting song parodies at this
point inspiration didn't really strike
twice for this movie and it didn't for
us either so just go scream into the
unknown as loud as you can until you
pass out you get the gist
starring frosty the sidekick the last
black man in Arundale they look like big
strong hands don't they
toothless Norwegian Rhapsody the best
friend from a rom-com that plays
basketball with the male weed the blink
and you'll miss it gay character the
Disney will pad itself on the back about
kid sister kids sister
wherever I froze she goes the fifth
element rise of ice Walker
[Music]
well Olaf's only three years old and
he's already doing observational comedy
every errand alien ship has a
compartment waterproof that's very
clever although it does make me wonder
why they don't just make the whole
ship's waterproof
this episode is sponsored by google play
yet Disney Princess majestic quest and
discover more on Google Play take me to
your leader or Robert Downey jr.
depending on who's nearest the foremost
world renowned international school of
lucha I am Spartacus